what are fractions and what are their
types
let's see
here's the example of a fraction 3 over
5 this says that if we have 5 equal
parts and we take 3 parts from it then
we will get 3 over 5. here we call 3 as
the numerator and 5 is the denominator
when the numerator is less than the
denominator it is called a proper
fraction so 2 over 5 and phi over 9 are
proper fractions when the numerator is
greater or equal to the denominator it
is called an improper fraction
examples are 7 over 6 or 12 over 11. the
fractions which you are seeing now
having similar denominators are called
like fractions and fractions with
different denominators are called unlike
fractions
to understand such important basic
concepts do follow us and don't forget
to share this video